we're back after four days off
and juan soto is back as well soto not
in the nationals lineup today but
activated after spending the first week
and a half
of the season on the covid ils
patrick corbin is back on the mound
today his second start
of the 2020 season brandon nimmo
left-handed batter with speed their lead
off guy
in the shift 2-2 swing and a miss
on the slider away to brandon
corbin now nine k's without a walk he
makes it look like
a strike most of the way and that's how
this one starts
so one out base runner now alonso so
he's over his last 11 and one for his
last 18.
02 with one out swaying and a miss
corbin gets ahead and then sort of toys
with the hitter with that
nasty outfit here's adam eaton who's in
all seven games for the nats this year
and eaton goes down on strikes matt's
gets him with a change up for the second
out
so now howie kendrick one of the real
heroes
for the nationals last year in their
world series run
this is a big one to left center
see you later
they passed along personal messages to
their nets
and howie says i'm tired of people
catching
my line drives
[Applause]
so back to back two out hits against
matt's and now starling castro is off to
a hot start
and goes back to the curve ball to get
castro and that retires aside
second strikeout for mats but kendrick's
home run puts the nats in front
josh harrison over four is annette
josh harrison deep to left c
u later how about that for a first
knock with your new team
dancing on the dugout what's going on
here i love it
brandon nimmo will be the batter now
corbin's o2
fastball ring him up strike three called
92 over the outside corner
nimmo caught looking he's out on strikes
for the second time here's jd davis the
third baseman
and he will have to lead off the fourth
patrick corbin two k's in a row
pitching well with a two run
howie kendrick will be the better
kendrick launched a home run to left
center his first time up
oh my barreled the other way
and you talk about this often after you
pull one they're gonna work you away
and then howie just hammers one that way
well
that's the howie kendrick i remember
right a tough out a guy that stayed on
everything hit the ball the other way
with authority
man how far out was that pitch and he
hit it fair into the right field corner
howie heading for third chapel will hold
him
second and third one out
as the right-handed batters are using
the other side of the yard
well here's a great opportunity for
starland to
get into the rbi column here
castro to right center on the ground on
a haptic and forto
everybody moves up 90 feet it's
three-nothing and castro gets his first
rbi
as annette runners at the corners with
one out
and this one out to left nimo has to
back up a bit
cabrera at third
everybody's safe good running to get the
second with two outs for castro
with the way these balls are just flying
to right field to left field this year
that's well hit on the ground to
conforto with one hop
throw home not even close and
ki boom checks in with an rbi to make it
five nothing
grounded into the shift his first time
up and forth
this one well out to left that goes
harrison to the warning track at the
wall
it's out of here michael conforto with
an opposite field two-run homer to get
the mets going
second home run of the year for conforto
amazing when a hitter has a pitchers
number
met with an opportunity here they get
alonzo to the plate as the tying run
in a five to two game again the 3-2
and alonso drives it the other way and
that's down for a base hit
nemo comes in to score davis goes to
third peav alonso with an opposite field
single to drive in a run
and now it's 5-3 washington well that's
a good sign right there from
petey the only time pete alonso has
faced rainey
one at bat one home run and he bats here
with the tying runs on base and nobody
out in the seventh
swing and a miss on the 96
basketball comes some pretty heavy
shower
and this one has conforto looking up
into the raindrops
oh and he makes a not easy
catch the seventh inning is over it's
raining hard in dc
and it's five to three and here comes
the tarp we're underway at 10
59 so it's a one hour and
seven minute rain delay well trying to
set the stage for a smooth top of the
night there you shall see
hudson's fourth game three and two
thirds one hit
nothing else offensively at all
ramos to center it got in on him just
enough
robles waiting and the nets have won
three in a row